(intense music)
- [George] Lordstown Motors.
At one point, the company was racing
to build America's first
all-electric pickup.
- They make 'em in Lordstown, Ohio.
I heard the sales are great.
- It had for a design for a
truck, a factory to make it in,
and hundreds of millions
of dollars in investment.
But then, the wheels fell
off Lordstown Motors.
Its share price plummeted.
It's namesake factory was sold off,
and now, the future of
its pickup, the Endurance,
is in question.
So what exactly happened
to Lordstown Motors?
(intense music continues)
(light music)
Our story starts,
somewhat unsurprisingly,
here, Lordstown, Ohio, 2019.
General Motors have been
making the Chevrolet Cruze here
for years, but a drop in sales
led to the company wanting
to close the plant,
which led to protests and drew criticism
from then President Donald Trump.
- What's going on with General Motors?
Get that plant open or sell it to somebody
and they'll open it.
- [George] GM did just that.
They gave a new EV
startup a $40 million loan
to buy the plant complete with
machinery for $20 million.
The startup would be named
after the neighborhood
itself, Lordstown Motors.
Its founder was the former chief executive
of another fledgling automotive
startup called Workhorse,
a man named Steve Burns.
- We think we're going to
do the impossible here.
- [George] Burns licensed a vehicle design
from his former company, Workhorse,
and set about entering the race
to build the first EV pickup.
And remember, this is
before Ford's F-150 Lighting
or Rivian's R1T had been released.
- Our first vehicle
is the Endurance
all-electric pickup truck.
- Armed with a factory
and a design for a truck,
all the company needed now was money.
So in August, Lordstown announced
it intended to go public
through a merger with a special
purpose acquisition company.
And investor sentiment
around the company soared,
lifted, like many others in the EV market,
by a wave of investors on
the hunt for the next Tesla.
But also, partly because the company said
it had around 27,000 pre-orders,
plus $75 million of investment from GM.
- The financing that comes
from being publicly listed
is the last piece we needed
as we march towards production in 2021.
- But Lordstown's RIDE was
about to get a lot bumpier.
(somber music)
In the early hours of January 13, 2021,
an Endurance caught fire
on a road in Michigan
while being tested by Lordstown engineers.
Lordstown said the fire was
due to nonconforming parts
on the prototype battery.
And before long, the company's
share price began to tumble.
Around that time, several top executives
at Lordstown sold off
chunks of their own stock,
though the company later
concluded there was no wrongdoing
and that the sales were
made for reasons unrelated
to the performance of the company.
Then came the bidding
for a United States
Postal Service contract
for a fleet of new electric vehicles.
Now, Lordstown hadn't submitted a bid
to design and build those trucks,
but remember Workhorse?
Well, it had, and it was
expected to manufacture
those trucks in Lordstown's factory.
But then...
- Oshkosh Defense of Oshkosh, Wisconsin
has been awarded the production contract
for the Postal Service's next
generation delivery vehicles.
(attendees applauding)
- Workhorse didn't win,
and Lordstown's shares tumbled further.
But it still had further to fall.
(somber music)
In March, short seller Hindenburg
Research accused Lordstown
of misleading investors
on, among other things,
how firm its pre-orders were.
Saying that many of them
were largely fictitious.
The report led
to a Securities and
Exchange Commission inquiry,
and later, a Justice
Department investigation.
And although then CEO, Steve Burns,
told "WSJ" in March 2021
that the report contained
half-truths and lies
and denied misrepresenting the order book,
he eventually resigned
after a board committee
found inaccuracies in
the company's pre-orders.
I tried to reach Burns for comment,
but I was unable to do so.
Finally, by the middle of 2021,
the company announced that
it didn't have enough funds
to begin full commercial production.
Lordstown needed money, fast.
(mysterious music)
Enter Foxconn, yep, the
Taiwanese iPhone manufacturer.
The company had said it had
ambitions to assemble EVs
for a variety of customers
on a contract basis,
much like it does with its phones.
Foxconn wanted a factory and
Lordstown needed capital,
so the two companies struck an agreement.
Lordstown would sell its
namesake factory to Foxconn
for $230 million,
and Foxconn would build
Lordstown's vehicle.
That was the plan anyway.
Production finally started for awhile
and then stopped again shortly after
when the company found a problem with some
of its electrical connectors.
- [Edward] We filed paperwork
with the National Highway
Traffic Safety Administration
to voluntarily recall the Endurance.
- Lordstown recalled all vehicles
that were out in the wild,
all 19 of them.
And shortly after, the
company's share price,
which at one point had been over $30,
fell below $1 and stayed
there for more than 30 days,
triggering a delisting notice from Nasdaq.
That led to Foxconn saying
that Lordstown has breached
its agreement and that Foxconn
would back out of the deal
if the matter wasn't resolved.
To try and fix the issue,
Lordstown announced that it was
doing a reverse stock split,
merging 15 shares into one,
to try and raise the price above $1.
Oh, and just before all that happened,
another Lordstown vehicle caught fire.
This time, a test vehicle in storage.
Lordstown said it would
investigate the cause.
(light music)
All that brings us to the present day.
Lordstown has said it hopes
its reverse stock split
will lead to Foxconn
returning to the deal.
If Foxconn does, then there may be hope
for the Endurance yet.
But if it doesn't and Lordstown
can't find other funding,
the company says it may seek to file
for bankruptcy protection.
I spoke to Foxconn and Lordstown,
but neither would comment on the deal.
But within its SEC filings
lies another big hurdle.
Lordstown says the cost
to build the Endurance
is currently, and expected
to continue to be,
substantially higher
than its selling price.
And that makes what
happens next for Lordstown
even more challenging.
In the three years that the company
has been navigating its
various production woes,
others, including Ford and Rivian,
have been delivering their
EV pickups to customers.
And more trucks, among them
the Chevy Silverado EV,
are on the way.
And with the cheapest Silverado
set to be around $20,000
cheaper than the Endurance,
not only has Lordstown
lost the race to be first,
but it may now struggle
to compete altogether.
(light music continues)